foreign
what's your favorite scary movie
Ghostface is back and scary as ever
Now's the Time to make a new screen
because we had a special story to tell
that connects the legacy cast members
with a new cast into the world of
Woodsboro
my character of Sam becomes the target
of the Ghost Face Killer who is this
someone who knows your little secret
she seeks Dewey for help Dewey he's
pulled back in because he's still got a
huge heart and really wants to help
Sydney she's moved on in her life
it's happening three attacks so far and
then chaos ensues
it's just the perfect mix of new energy
and also keeping him what made it so
special in the first place I don't think
it's exactly what people are expecting
there's things that happen in this that
are kind of shocking I still can't
believe it
I've been through this a lot whoever
this is is going to keep coming for you
so so I want you to help us kill him so
many twists and turns who's the killer
who's not we don't know
sounds about right
[Applause]
[Music]